-I do want to have this --
Well, I've been asking people,
"Do you think Trump
is a worse client,
or Rudy Giuliani is
a worse lawyer?"
Where do you come out on that?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, this is
a very difficult question.
-It is, right?
-Uh, I would say --
-This is like a question
that, like, in order
to get over a bridge,
like, a troll would ask you.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
"Monty Python
and the Holy Grail."
-Exactly.
-I -- I would say
that Rudy Giuliani is perhap
the worst lawyer
that anyone could have.
-Yeah.
-And I would point to this
which just came out
within the last 24 hours.
-Mm-hmm.
In "The New Yorker,"
Giuliani quoted as saying,
we had to get rid of
Yovanovitch,
this courageous former
ambassador to Ukraine,
because she was going to
get in the way
of these investigations.
I mean, it was just anothe
full-throated confession.
And so I don't know
what kind of malpractice
that is,
but nonetheless, you know,
on a serious note,
what he has admitted --
what the president
has admitted --
when the president is
out on the White House lawn,
and he's asked, "What did yo
want on that phone call,
when the president,
in his own words,
asked for this favor --"
the Ukraine president brings up,
"We need more military help,
and the president said,
"But I have a favor, though" -
"what did you want him to do?"
And the president says,
"Well, if we're being honest
about it,
it's a simple answer.
He should investigate
the Bidens."
And it was interesting
because he was asked
about, "What did you want
at the time?"
but his answer was
what he wants right now.
He still wants an investigatio
of the Bidens.
And if not by Ukraine,
then by China.
And this was why
we felt an imperative
to move forward with
the articles of impeachmen
that we did,
because the threat
is ongoing.
The plot has never stopped
His efforts to get
foreign countries
to help him cheat
in the next election
are a continuing threat
to our democracy.
But he continues,
and his lawyer continues,
to make the case
for his own removal.
-And yet, obviously,
we're in a situation,
based on what would have t
happen in the Senate,
it is very unlikely
that he is going to be voted
to be impeached
and out of office.
You mentioned, like,
this is something
where you're going to say
to your grandkids
what you did in this moment.
Do you feel as though, you know,
if the outcome is
what can be expected,
which is he's not going to
leave office from this,
has it been worth it
to impeach him in the House,
which obviously will happe
on Wednesday?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Again, if they were --
If they were senators,
we'd be in a whole different
situation right now.
-The answer is yes.
And I say that --
And I was someone
who was reluctant
to go down this road.
But two things
changed my mind.
The first was
this latest misconduct
involving this shakedown
of a country at war.
And a shakedown that damages
our own national security
was just a bridge too far.
But also it was
the issue of timing.
The day after
Bob Mueller testified,
the day after he talked abou
Russia's interference
in our last election,
how they might interfere
in the next election,
Trump believes
it's finally over.
And the next day, he's on th
phone with Zelensky,
asking for yet another country
to intervene
in yet another election.
That said to me, this presiden
believes he is above the law
accountable to no one,
can't be indicted,
he's got his Roy Cohn
in Bill Barr
at the Justice Department,
can't be impeached,
he is utterly beyond
any form of accountability
That is too dangerous a
situation to go unchallenged
And so we do what we must.
The fact that the Republican
may or may not honor
their Constitutional duty
doesn't mean that we
relinquish our own.
-All right, thanks so much
for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's Adam Schiff.